don't cough it'll fall over
we've been dating for I want to say
three and a half years now yeah like six
buds I think all those oh but who's
counting we've been dating like nine
months sure today we are building a desk
I've never built furniture period we've
built a lot of furniture together I'm
not handy at all I have no building
skill I'm already put on illegit
instructions you have a photo but it
supposed to look like you've had the
last page of the instructions it's
missing like all of the inside of it
that's not fair
goes from 2 to 39 page that was just
like a joke in the beginning I trust our
guys but I don't know if she can do it
in 30 minutes so yeah we're gonna see
all right so what does a desk clerk
Hawaii you know what if this look
exciting we should just like put the
boards in that position that one that's
the top that's step one the lack of
instructions is really killing me right
now
why does it'll just go completely
outside the box and this is hard I got
so excited these things stick in the
same thing there's two bowls here this
tool was here oh well pretty much
anything so like Lawless wait do they
match up for how to be in a relationship
okay we have to just talk through I feel
like I'm at that point now where it's
like if I don't get more information and
stuff what we were in another page oh
sweet oh my god it's still missing [ __ ]
oh my god that's cool that's all I need
just giving you started okay this is
direction one she's doing the bigger
draw I'm doing the smaller draw she's
way better understanding the directions
whereas I am better at actually doing
them everyone has like stresses
relationship if you're with the right
person then you guys can help each other
with those problems so that's why I
think we work well together we could
work on the frame could function as a
desk if needed like are you gonna get to
this you really like prioritize one
thing at a time ever gotten in a fight
building furniture authorities walked
away oh yeah I normally I'm just sitting
there for the rest of my building a
Punisher
come back a little bit with a glass of
wine and to take a breather then I come
back and then oh I'll keep helping I
would have broken up with him I wouldn't
went on I didn't like he doesn't know
how to do a damn thing and neither do I
this is horrible oh great forgiveness
okay and I'm gonna give you instructions
really quickly and you're gonna have to
pay attention to me okay we're gonna
hold it by the time you gave us the
instructions we were already doing stuff
so why not just keep doing that stuff we
could do this do you can you could have
enough you make a bad decision you
continue me you don't give up halfway
half a screw in half throughout you can
pay people to do these things for you
building it does you have to communicate
like you have to communicate and a lot
of times like you have to work together
we're gonna get a thing that stands it
has two legs suppose have three legs
yeah whatever you should never do it
what your hand you always wanna do it
your screwdriver we're seeing the step
way up
no that's no what goes there could you
see how just now like she's like you got
to put it started off with the
screwdriver like no but I want to put it
in with my hand first and just like no
use a screwdriver like yeah like then ya
help me help me make the stand I don't
embarrass myself that much [ __ ] Oh see
she's a perfectionist she's really
putting in every screw we have the
directions
there's really something huh man if
we're moving like this if you first got
this way okay we're not like other
couples for stupid couple right on down
it's gonna smash my finger where's the
this is called minimalism I don't know
if you've heard of it just pull with us
it together yeah what you're not letting
now we're just like alternative winning
oK we've built a desk
next time you are on a date make sure
you have an instruction manual 30
minutes was definitely difficult it does
compared to relationships you're not
giving a book or instructions on how to
love someone or how to be with someone
sometimes you have to make do with what
you have it really does represent a
relationship ed how it's barely big held
together and how okay we are is it make
it where it's my best friend so doing
anything together is always fun as long
as we communicate like I said before we
get a minute it's cool
[Music]